モンスターハンターダブルクロス
2つをマスターしましたん
はいこんにちははじめ社長ですね
モンスターハンターダブルクロスなラスボスと言っていいのかわかんないんですけど元
からそのストーリー上が過ごすというのは2日間で何とか打つ倒しました
あの
気が済まないわけです僕はこの2日間で競っていくとこまでいってやろうと思ってやっ
てう気合でちょっとラスボスっぽい奴を倒したので量やってね
まあまあラスボスってもねまぁようやくここでねやっとあの
フォースターハンターのスタートラインに立ったと言ってもまあ過言ではないですね
いやぁ今回はなかなか面白かったです何書こうか誰かですねここがロボットねこう
いろんな要素があるしまだまだやってないクエスト何で食うからなんですけどもきっと
バス者のラスボスチック熱を倒すとハンターランクっていうのが開放されましてあり
まさにこれですね阪大なんか今35普通にやってると束12までなんですけども茄子の
素トースト35まで上がります
僕はもう流行っている時は動画とっておいたんで多分ねこれはもう版があるあると言っ
ても過言じゃない
4人とかでもう流行ってる人は多分こんな感じなんだろうなっていうあのもう版ある的
な動画になっていると思うので是非そちらをご覧下さい
どうぞ誰も見てください
結構強いんだろうなぁ
強いず何なんですよねぇお願い
何か辺くださいそう
よっ
食べればいいじゃないよぞああああああああ
ああああああ
ターを与党0分ああ
追われ汚れ待ってくれ本文行ったよ a 1発に打ったね
ブーバーし
形もコロいえ寒いなぁなぁいい学びまして路上わー
あってございました
をゲットぉ車はぁパーティシーン
もう行きです
スマっぽいはぁっ
あああああに hi ko
ちょっと山て号から通ってる子になったら条件を
[音楽]
ブービー4 r 1の小さなデリバードは完璧なコラボレーションだった
パッ大悪女という間にバー関係やたい奴ローっわけですねもうぞ
はいああああ
ふーんんやっちゃいましょうこのさっそく本ぞ
このサーモンの足元だけマジ最強なんですこれは少しから振っも凝っホラー素晴らしい
た
いうで予定
はいじゃあずないぞ
ありがとねその他バッグに移ってくるこれ降ってくるよ
避けて開けてあーあ no ai だ6えっパスはやばい7世代
ナチュラル防御大ちゃいけないですんこちゃんも立ループレバーは誰か助けて誰か
いやーもないそれマックダイナーやはいはい海の神様ではー
うわああああああああ
rar 俺 osarusan
ねー
a 1年 t 財産として来いピンちゃんですよろしくのピンチチャンスです bye
ああ
バーナーインナーに投げなきゃいけ投げるよ
小屋いい
ああやれねぇはーい
wh
よね激辛人権ってと爪をもうやばい結構やばいっ
ていうかこれでしたねーのはぁっ
予習絞ってさあいさあホラー
アイエエエエ
ame
ああああああ
はあああああを作れました袋祖母ん坊
質実はいますまあオンライン出るのもいいんですけどもやっぱこうで直接会って4人
ちゃんとコミュニケーションを取りながらやるモンスターハンターが僕は一番面白いと
思っております初の日か2日ホームごはん食べてなかったんですけどもさっき体重計で
測ったら3キロ減ってました
いえーい
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
あっはぁ